a lot of people having questions about
how do I get over the fear of failure
how do I say why not instead of yes but
there the word about the execution of it
how do i how do they do it what what
advice you have for them it's coming up
repeating oh I kind of got a little note
you know there's little note things yeah
and someone that let's ask me yeah but
I'm afraid but I'm afraid but I'm afraid
of you were so unafraid Michael and I
said that but that's ridiculous
everybody's afraid everybody Einstein
was afraid um Steve Jobs was afraid I'm
afraid you're afraid every one of us
afraid so what do I do about fear I
wrote down on this little note thing I
create my way through fear hmm write it
down I create my way through fear I
accept the fact that yes but is simply a
sign that I'm afraid so my inner voice
comes up with all the reasons why not
I'm suggesting the minute you know that
you simply go beyond it so how do you
overcome your fear of success you become
successful and then how do you overcome
your fear of becoming even more
successful you become even more
successful and how do you overcome your
fear of becoming even more more more
successful is Italy become more more
more successful meaning you just keep
doing it you understand you just keep
doing it what do you keep doing what
you're called to do if it's beyond where
you are if it is where you are more of
the same I'm saying you attract to you
this mindset old co nico nico is what's
next
old co is what exists today old co is
always what exists today and most people
hang on to old co for fear of losing old
co so they don't risk creating new come
you follow let go the minute you let go
you understand there's just now and now
there's no fear because there's no then
there's no past there's no future
there's no there's just now now we're in
it now we are it now we're creating it
now we're evolving with it now we're
discovering what in fact is true what
isn't true what inhibits me from seeing
what's true etc etc etc I mean it's
called being alive that's all that's all
it is it's called being fully alive when
you talk about fire it's just energy you
understand it's just energy what's life
energy what's creativity and expression
of energy what's an opportunity it's a
opportunity to express your energy in a
more perfect way so if that's true
there's all that potential sitting here
waiting inside of us yes but we'll kill
that potential